viele spritzen müssen sie im impfzentrum
in mainz im moment nicht aufziehen etwa
100 menschen lassen sich hier pro tag
impfen meist geht es um den ersten oder
zweiten booster bundesweit sind
inzwischen gut 76 prozent der
bevölkerung grund immunisiert viele drei
mal geimpft aktuell schleppt das im
tempo wird aber vermutlich im herbst
wieder fahrt aufnehmen mit auslieferung
der neuen impfstoffe wird sicherlich
hier wieder deutlich mehr die impfung
nachgefragt werden ob es dann eben bei
conti mobilisierten die dritte oder bei
anderen gruppen bereits eine eine
weitere hilfen sein soll mit der
zulassung der angepassten impfstoffe von
moderner und bayon tag wird in den
nächsten wochen gerechnet das vakzin von
beyond basiert auf der omicron variante
baa1 und dem ursprünglichen wildtyp die
kombination soll besseren schutz bieten
ein wichtiger schritt aber wohl kein so
genannter game changer
meiner sicht das wichtigste festzuhalten
dass alle im moment zugelassenen
impfstoffe sicher zuverlässig und
wirksam vor schweren ko mit 19 stützen
die neuen impfstoffe schützen zwar nach
allem was wir heute wissen auch vor
schweren verläufen allerdings scheint
kein wesentlich bessere infektionsschutz
gegeben zu sein deswegen wird es auch
danach trotz aller impfungen noch
infektionen geben auf vielen
intensivstationen ist corona wie hier in
kaiserslautern derzeit kein so großes
thema doch auch ohne corona sind sie
hier am limit von rund 50 intensivbetten
am standort können mindestens zwölf
dauerhaft nicht betrieben werden
pflegemangel ärztemangel
investitionsstau all das sei kaum noch
zu bewältigen
letztendlich befinden wir uns und das
müssen wir nicht beschönigen in einer
maximalen versorgungslücke in einem
gesundheitspolitischen tsunami den
können wir nicht mehr recht diskutiert
viele corona fälle im herbst wären dann
noch ein problem mehr und es darf nicht
zuviel personal krank werden darum
hoffen sie hier dass es nicht zu schlimm
wird und einiges spricht auch dafür denn
ein sehr großer teil der bevölkerung ist
inzwischen durch impfungen und
infektionen immunisiert
wir müssen jetzt vor allem die älteren
und chronisch kranken ausreichend gut
schützen hier spielt vor allem die
zweite musterung eine ganz entscheidende
rolle um schwere verläufe zu verhindern
und dann bin ich sehr zuversichtlich
dass wir zwar im märz steigende
infektionszahlen aber gleichzeitig keine
wesen steigenden wegen kohle topspeed
engagierten fans sehen werden der dritte
corona herbst kommt die
ausgangsbedingungen dieses jahr scheinen
besser als im letzten zu sein darüber
die gemengelage spreche ich jetzt mit
dem vize-vorsitzenden des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes markus beyer schouten
tag drückt also eine vierte impfung
möglicherweise schon ab september wie
wichtig wäre dass jetzt aus ihrer sicht
also die grundbotschaft ist wichtig und
essentiell impfen lassen ob erste zweite
oder dritte aber es gibt ganz viele
menschen die jetzt unbedingt auf diese
vierte impfung angewiesen sind und wir
beobachten ein bisschen mit sorge dass
die anfrage nach den impfungen noch zu
gering sind nach den vierten wie
erklären sie sich das ist liegt es daran
dass die leute vielleicht warten bis der
angepasste impfstoff kommt ja also das
damit sollte man nicht taktieren die
impfungen der jetzige im stoff ist sehr
gut und im zweifelsfall wie viel
wichtiger jetzt zu impfen als auf etwas
zu warten und es ist auch so diese
irrige meinung diese impfung würde jetzt
sicher eine infektion verhindern das tut
sie nicht aber die schweren verläufe
verhindert sie die auswertung des ersten
jahres zeigen 20 millionen tote weltweit
wurden durch impfungen verhindert jetzt
ist es so dass die stiko sagt eine
vierte impfung eigentlich für die leute
ab 70 der gesundheitsminister möchte
gerne auch jüngere zum impfen bewegen
wie sehen sie das wer sollte sich jetzt
ein viertes mal wirklich impfen lassen
also wir sind da ganz pragmatisch wir
halten uns einerseits nach den
wissenschaftlichen empfehlungen der
stiko und andererseits behandeln wie
immer einzelne menschen schauen uns die
krankheitsbilder an und da spielt es
jetzt nicht die rolle ob derjenige 69
oder 71 ist es gibt 60 jährige sind so
krank wie 75-jähriger also wir können
den menschen nur sagen kommen sie in
unsere praxen wir schauen uns die
individuelle situation an und werden
dann sehr großzügig zum impfen raten
grundsätzlich gilt aber für uns die
stiko empfiehlt jetzt gibt es viele
diskussionen über das impfen es gibt in
diskussionen über das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz inwieweit
belastet denn dieses politische gerangel
auch ihre arbeit also diskussion und wo
empfehlungen auseinanderdriften wo sich
regel schnell ändern die belasten unsere
arbeit immer weil die nachfrage dann bei
uns landen am telefon am tresen im
sprechzimmer
das ist in so einer situation die wir
seit zweieinhalb jahren haben sich ja
nicht ganz zu vermeiden aber alle
sollten sich bemühen möglichst mit einem
ziel und klar zu kommunizieren
jetzt gibt es das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz für den herbst
ist das ihrer meinung nach ausreichend
und sinnvoll also ist es zum einen so
dass es gut ist dass es jetzt schon so
früh kommt das dass sich die menschen
und alle darauf vorbereiten können es
sind auch viele gute dinge mit dabei
sind so ein paar sachen dabei die wir
nicht ganz glücklich sind diese
bevorzugung von frisch gebürsteten nur
drei monate lang ist so ein bisschen
wieder neuer zeitrahmen da gibt es
geimpfte erster und zweiter klasse nicht
ganz einfach warum ich in der u bahn
dann keine maske tragen soll im ic in
den nicht einsteigt aber schon auch so
ein bisschen eine schwierige sache nur
so zwei beispiele insgesamt aber positiv
wie schauen sie in den herbst und winter
der jetzt kommt wir schauen schon
besorgt und hoffen dass die menschen
wirklich mitziehen weil wir hatten in
den praxen das zweite jahr
hintereinander keine sommerpause letztes
jahr haben wir geimpft wie die
weltmeister und jetzt sind seit anfang
juni die infect zahlen immens hoch und
die belastung in den praxen ist enorm
sie müssen bedenken wir behandeln noch
über 90 prozent aller corona fälle in
den hausärztlichen praxen das heißt die
menschen kommen zu ihnen brauchen auch
individuelle beratung das haben sie eben
angesprochen wenn menschen eben wissen
wollen ob es sich lohnt sich impfen zu
lassen oder nicht über den neu
angepassten impfstoff haben wir eben
gerade schon gesprochen wenn jetzt viele
auf den warten was passiert eigentlich
mit dem eigenen impfstoff dann also ich
kann dieses warten überhaupt nicht
empfehlen weder medizinisch ist das
zeitfenster
entstehen indem man ungeimpften gebucht
hat ist das kann ich niemandem empfehlen
wer jetzt dran ist für die zweite dritte
oder vierte impfung der sollte jetzt
kommen und diesen guten aktuellen
impfstoff nutzen und auch nichts warten
was irgendwann kommt sagt der
vize-vorsitzende des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes markus beyer vielen
dank für das gespräch dann gehen